yo this is dr. John Delaney with Ramsey
Network what's up I hope you having a
good week hope everybody in your world
is safe healthy and that you're just
being chill you're being kind
hope everybody's back to work whoo all
right we are taking you ask John and
Ramsey solutions comm emails today we've
got a new one I'm going to call this cat
Tom I had a buddy named Tom when I was a
kid
best guitar player you'll ever see he
was awesome so Tom here you go this
isn't actually Tom but you know I mean
so here we go doctor de Loney what's up
what's up I'm inclined to believe that
my last relationship ended because I was
emotionally abusive you're correct I
don't even know what the rest that says
you're correct
I was critical controlling and I've
heard rumors that there will be a
picture of us added to the definition of
codependency and the 2021 version of
Webster's for you Millennials out there
Webster's was a dictionary it's a big
huge book that print off parts of the
internet and just charge you 100 million
dollars for it was awesome anyway I was
wondering if you had any advice or books
that you could recommend that would help
prevent me from making the same mistakes
in the future Thanks this took a lot of
guts to send this email so I'm grateful
to you for sending it for a dude to look
in the mirror and say I was critical
controlling and codependent I applaud
you man that's hard and not a lot of
dudes have the courage and the
vulnerability to do that so way to go
I'm proud of you all right so what do
you do
number one you admit there's a problem
you've done that here number two you've
got to find somebody that you can be in
contact with probably in your situation
I'd go get with a counselor or a
psychologist that you trust a mental
health professional that you trust that
you can sit down and say I'm controlling
I'm a jerk I haven't dealt with nonsense
from my childhood my guess here is you
saw some stuff and you're a kid and
you've got a seven year old or an eight
year old inside still protecting you
from all the junk and that disconnection
that you experienced in your kid that's
just my guess but this is a time
email so I'm making that up as I go it
probably also is a response to the fact
that you feel like life's out of control
and the things that you can control are
things that are smaller than you that
you can hover over instead of be with
and a lot of dudes who struggle with
being critical and hyper controlling and
hyper codependent have not understood
they have no model in their life for how
to be with somebody they just have a
model for how to control how to be over
how to lord over how to exert power that
usually comes because they've got bigger
muscles or whatever so you're gonna need
to get professional help is gonna be my
recommendation number three any advice
or books you could recommend the number
one book by a landslide by a hundred
miles is a book by Terrance a real call
I don't want to talk about it the
subtitle of that book is the secret
legacy of male depression I wouldn't
have put that subtitle on there because
that just assures that dudes won't read
it but I don't want to talk about it my
Terrance reel is the best book you could
possibly read on this wives girlfriends
boyfriends everybody should read that
book it's a it's a pretty remarkable
read about this idea of women were lied
to and it came to what they need in
relationships and men we're not only
lied to they just weren't told anything
and they're operating under an old model
of how relationships work and
relationships in the modern world expect
and demand a lot from both partners and
so they've got to communicate
communicate communicate and connect
right so the fourth and the last thing I
would do is tell you this you got to get
a group of men in your life that will
challenge you that will hold you
accountable that will demand
authenticity from you and that will
demand that you do positive things for
your romantic partner in the future I
remember I had a group of guys like this
in a small Texas town that I used to
live in and one of the the men in my
life that played a really important role
in my life has got him Slade Sullivan
he's a lawyer in Texas I knew that every
Monday morning we got together he would
ask all the guys hit on the table what's
one thing you did for your wife last
week and there was some Sunday nights
I'm ashamed to admit that
did something for my wife that night so
that I would have something to say the
following Monday morning and that's not
cool but over time it became a way I was
thinking of what's something I could do
nice for my wife today I want something
I could do for my night my wife this
week and then I faded and abdun flowed
and then over the next several years I
realized dude I control my thoughts and
it became like a muscle this idea of
controlling my thoughts and over time
with practice and intentionality every
day I wake up now looking for ways I can
serve my wife and looking for ways I can
serve my kids and looking for ways I can
serve my neighbor and my co-workers he
just became a muscle that you got to
practice and I still got to practice it
every day in those days I screwed up and
I messed it up but it's intentionality
and all that comes back to a group of
guys that held me accountable I've got a
few friends in my life
Kevin Todd John other friends Trevor
Craig those guys that are my go-to guys
Jeff that will ask me hey how's your
marriage how are you doing right now and
that's because I've been vulnerable and
let him in and said hey I got screwed up
my marriage again I messed this up I
should have said this in a different way
I shouldn't have been X and why's it and
those are guys that hold me accountable
and so you've got to find yourself a
group okay so you gotta admit it well
done number two you got to get a
professional here you got to get it go
see a counselor have the courage to go
see somebody number three I don't want
to talk about it by Terrence real
world-class book and number four you got
to get a group of guys in your life
they're gonna hold you accountable thank
you so much for wanting better for you
better for the person that you're going
to end up marrying and better for all of
us as neighbors and community members I
applaud your brother good luck this is
dr. John Bologna saying thank you so
much for watching keep sitting in your
emails that ask John at Ramsey solutions
com
subscribe follow at the interwebs
stations I guess it's not like a space
just at John des lunes do that and I
will talk to you soon take care of rock
on be cool